[Music]
privyet yeah Aria and over in the US we
hear a lot about Russia like a lot I
would consider the principal threat to
start with Russia prosecutors indict
another batch of Russian nationals in an
alleged cyber scheme to interfere in the
2016 presidential election Russia Russia
Russia Russia Russia and in the midst of
all these fire storms I'm here while
Russia is hosting the 2018 FIFA World
Cup which for now is giving their people
a chance to be seen in a different light
so while my Russian buddy Erik can't
join me
I've luckily met Kristina here to help
me out as I explore the Russian capital
how do you say cow in Russian good car
over got over what is that they cool you
can now break the law this is an
international terrorist incident
we are here in various cuffs yeah yeah
we're here in a square all right we're
at this Georgian place wasn't even
declared restaurant jauntily
judge it what are things I guess you
think I should know or be aware of about
Russia Russia is a big country really
very big and it has a lot of people and
people are really very different
some people are open-minded they want to
be friends with all over the world and
some people hate everyone
it's because their life is hard with
isolation brushes sometimes it's very
very hard we have a lot of poor people
we have lots of problems inside the
country but we have to make our life
better ourselves no one will help us not
the government not the president only we
can make our life better to learn more
about daily life here
I decided chat with some locals trivia
you know we should trade music so you
know what's a good Russian luna tractor
boy in car while you shoot tomato plant
from a synthetic or do you like it
already
I'm digging I Cristina you guys watch or
listen to like western music Media TV
Big Bang Theory Big Bang Theory
Metallica sleep I'm out to be on so far
you know wow that's the face of even
Americans maker what I was gonna tell
people that I'm more of a Michael Buble
guys you guys like Michael Buble is it
Michael Buble maybe they know I'm more
as like a MeetMe Kyle Buble how do you
say voice of an angel in Russian I can
get ask Eagles and I promise few kids
that I give so much more than I get I
just haven't met you yet how do you feel
the day when we've been filming you look
at me like I'm a crazy person there's a
lot of stereotypes about Russia I mean
are there any stereotypes or myths you
can debug for us in our country and in
our cities don't live in beers we don't
have various aspects unless you let me
know fires in the street I work you talk
about the Bears look around
beers very beers a show menu POV cars
the game world there may be a stereotype
that we're gloomy and not a friendly but
very nice and we don't like ponies we
are open to different cultures but how
do Russians actually feel about the
United States but country with whom they
have such a complicated history
I've been an exchange student for one
year in Utah oh you live in Utah yes
exactly one year I was 16 back then and
I used to live in the Mormon family and
it was the best time of
when I think about America I remember
about American Hollywood American
support but non-negative
Oh negative it depends on a generation
perhaps for the older generation it's
they kind of strictly they don't like
the bollocks to the politics I think
it's quality yes I talked about a
politics
I know some people maybe one or two per
se some that was about us but this is
not my friends this is another people
and this is people who never be in US
and I for Americans watching I told you
hope that they learn or take away about
Russia the you article and Mira people
be adjustable name the best in world
it's peace and you want to peace and we
wanted this guy's from us guys from
Russia
we are friends forever and ever and ever
Russia and us forever
that was really moving man thank you
Russia is a country embroiled in a lot
of controversy and a day in Moscow is
hardly enough to capture everything
about an entire nation and while this
video can only provide a small slice of
life here I'm glad today gave me a
chance to meet some great people who
ultimately proved to be no different
than you or me or most others on this
silly planet so for now I'll just leave
you with some wise words from a Russian
cat I bet that though ideally videos now
do you hug in Russia
hey unsolved is on a new channel and now
you're part subscribe here that was my
part